- [Instructor] Acetic acid
is an example of a weak acid
and sodium hydroxide is an
example of a strong base.
When acetic acid reacts
with sodium hydroxide,
an aqueous solution of
sodium acetate is formed
along with water.
Since this reaction is an
acid-base neutralization reaction,
and these reactions go to completion,
instead of using an equilibrium arrow,
we simply draw an arrow
going to the right.
Next, let's write the
overall ionic equation.
This is also called the
complete ionic equation.
Let's start with acetic acid.
Acetic acid is a weak acid
that only partly ionizes in solution.
Therefore, an aqueous
solution of acetic acid,
most of the acetic acid
molecules stay protonated
and don't turn into acetate.
Therefore, we're just gonna
write CH3COOH down here.
We're not gonna show acetic acid ionizing
into H+ and the conjugate base.
However, things are different
for sodium hydroxide.
Sodium hydroxide is a strong base,
and strong bases dissociate
100% in solution.
So an aqueous solution of sodium hydroxide
consists of sodium cations
and hydroxide anions.
Next, let's think about our products.
We have an aqueous
solution of sodium acetate.
Sodium acetate is a soluble salt.
Therefore, in aqueous solution,
we would have sodium cations, Na+,
and the acetate anion, CH3COO-.
Because water ionizes only
to an extremely small extent,
we don't write it as the ions.
We simply write H2O.
To save some time, I've added
in some aqueous subscripts
and a liquid one for water,
some plus signs, and the reaction arrow.
So this balanced equation
represents the complete ionic equation.
Next, we're gonna use the
complete ionic equation
to write the net ionic equation
for this weak acid-strong base reaction.
And to do that,
we first need to identify spectator ions.
Remember, spectator ions don't
participate in the reaction.
So looking at the complete ionic equation,
there are sodium cations on the left
and sodium cations on the right,
so we can cross out the sodium cation,
that's our spectator ion.
After we take out the sodium cation,
what's left over is
our net ionic equation.
So for our net equation,
we have acetic acid plus hydroxide anion,
forms the acetate anion and water.
Now that we have our net ionic equation,
we're gonna think about
three different situations.
And the first situation,
we have equal moles of our
weak acid and our strong base.
Looking at our balanced
net ionic equation,
the mole ratio of our weak
acid to our strong base
is one-to-one.
Therefore, if we have equal
moles of our weak acid
and our strong base
and the mole ratio is one-to-one,
the weak and the strong base
are going to completely
neutralize each other
and form the acetate anion.
So if our goal is to figure out the pH
of the resulting solution,
we don't need to consider acetic acid
and we don't need to
consider the hydroxide ions
'cause these have been completely used up.
We need to think about the acetate anion
in aqueous solution.
And in aqueous solution,
acetate anions react with water
to form acetic acid and hydroxide ions.
This reaction does come to an equilibrium
and since Kb is less than one,
at equilibrium, there will be
a large amount of reactants
and only a small amount of products.
However, since we are
increasing the concentration
of hydroxide ions in solution,
the resulting solution will be basic.
Therefore, at 25 degrees Celsius,
the pH of the resulting solution
will be greater than seven.
If we wanted to calculate the actual pH,
we would need some more information,
but we would treat it
just like a weak base equilibria problem.
Also note that the hydroxide
ions that we wrote down here
are not the same thing
as the hydroxide ions
from our net ionic equation.
The hydroxide ions from
our net ionic equation
went away completely.
They were neutralized by
reacting with the acetic acid.
So these hydroxide ions were generated
from the anion hydrolysis
reaction of acetate plus water,
and even though it's only a small amount
or a small concentration
of hydroxide ions,
those are the hydroxide ions
that make the pH greater than seven.
For the second situation,
let's think about the
weak acid being in excess.
Since the mole ratio of our
weak acid to our strong base
is one-to-one,
if we have more of the weak acid
than we do have the strong base,
all of the strong base will be used up,
and we will form the acetate anion.
And when the reaction comes to completion,
there'll be no more
hydroxide ion in solution.
So if our goal is to find the
pH of the resulting solution,
we don't need to consider
the hydroxide ion at all
since it's all been used up.
We need to think about the weak acid
that was in excess, acetic acid,
and we also have to think
about the acetate anion
that was formed in the
neutralization reaction.
First, let's think about the
weak acid that was in excess.
Acetic acid will react with water
to form the hydronium ion, H3O+,
and the acetate anion, CH3COO-.
Because the concentration
of hydronium ions
in solution increases,
that makes the solution more acidic.
Therefore, when the
weak acid is in excess,
the pH of the resulting
solution will be less than seven
at 25 degrees Celsius.
If our goal is to calculate the actual pH
of the resulting solution,
our first thought would be,
this is a weak acid equilibria problem.
And it is, however,
there are two sources of acetate anion.
One source of acetate anion
is from the reaction of
acetic acid with water,
and then the other source
of the acetate anion
came from our acid-base
neutralization reaction.
Therefore, one way to think
about this problem is,
it's actually a common-ion effect problem
where the common ion is the acetate anion.
The presence of a common ion
decreases the ionization
of acetic acid in water.
However, since the
concentration of hydronium ions
will still increase,
the pH of the solution
will be less than seven.
Another way to think
about this problem is,
when we formed the acetate anion
from the neutralization reaction,
we had some of the weak acid in excess.
And when we have a weak acid
and its conjugate base present,
a buffer solution forms.
And so we could also use the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation
to calculate the pH of
the resulting solution.
For the third situation,
let's think about the
strong base being in excess.
Since the mole ratio of our weak acid
to our strong base is one-to-one,
if we have the strong base in excess,
the strong base is going to
neutralize all of the weak acid.
Therefore, when the reaction
comes to completion,
there will be no more weak acid present.
So if our goal is to find the
pH of the resulting solution,
we would just have to think
about the extra hydroxide ions
in solution.
And since there are extra hydroxide ions
from our strong base,
we know at 25 degrees Celsius,
the pH of the solution
will be greater than seven,
so the resulting solution will be basic.
If we wanted to calculate the
actual pH of the solution,
this would become a strong
base pH calculation problem.
And while it is true
that the acetate anions
that were produced from
the neutralization reaction
will react with water
to also increase the
concentration of hydroxide ions,
the concentration of hydroxide
ions that we would get
from the anion hydrolysis
of the acetate anion
would be negligible to the hydroxide ions
that were left over.
Therefore, we could just
consider the strong base
to calculate the pH,
and we don't need to worry
about anion hydrolysis
for this particular situation.